[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihn allen Trial and
Error also mal ein wenig rumprobieren
das ist tatsächlich eine anerkannte
Methode des Problemlösens für alle die
mit begrenztem wissen und wenig Zeit
dennoch zu praktikablen Ergebnissen
kommen wollen wenn aber die
Bundesregierung den Anschein erwgt
ebenfalls nach dieser Methode zu
arbeiten dann ist das eher weniger
zielführend wir haben jetzt einen guten
und fairen Weg gefunden sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister heute nachdem
seine Regierung einen Rückzieher gemacht
hat bei ihren ursprünglichen
Kürzungsplänen für die Landwirtschaft
die sollen jetzt nur noch teilweise
kommen die bauernproteste haben also
durchaus Wirkung gezeigt und dennoch
sind die Bauern nicht zufrieden Oliver
Decker im Schnitt rund 18 Liter pro
Stunde verbraucht der Trecker von
Landwirt Christian Fricke aus
schwiblingsen nah Hannover die
Entscheidung der Bundesregierung an der
KFZ Steuerbefreiung für
landwirtschaftliche Fahrzeuge
festzuhalten sei der richtige Weg aber
der Agrardiesel ist die weitaus größere
der weitaus größere Posten der bei uns
auch im Betrieb mehr als 70% dieser
geplanten Kürzung ausmacht und dies
jetzt auf zwei Jahre zu verschieben ist
ein Sterben auf Raten und wir stehen in
zwei Jahren wieder vor dem Punkt und
deswegen werden wir an unseren Protesten
festhalten denn wir fordern eine
komplette Rücknahme dieser Maßnahmen das
forderten am Morgen in Hannover auch die
niedersächsische Landesregierung und
Agrarverbände in einer gemeinsamen
Erklärung appellieren sie an die
Bundesregierung die
Steuervergünstigungen für Landwirte
nicht zu
kippen wir tun das weil wir den Eindruck
haben dass diese Vorschläge unausgewogen
sind dass sie insbesondere auch eine
Wirtschaftsform übermäßig Treffen im
Vergleich zu vielen anderen der
Schulterschluss von Landespolitikern mit
landwirtschaftsverbänden der Druck von
der Straße mit teilweise hunderten
Treckern und zornigen Bauern haben die
Ampelkoalition offenbar zum Umdenken
bewogen wir haben gemeinsam eine gute
gefunden die eine überproportionale
Belastung sie wissen davor habe ich
immer gewnt der Land und Forstwirtschaft
abwendet so soll die Steuerbegünstigung
beim Agrardiesel jetzt schrittweise
auslaufen 2024 reduziert sich der
entlastungssatz um 40% 2025 und 26 dann
noch einmal um jeweils 30% damit ist
diese Subvention 2026 ausgelaufen aber
den Betrieben wurde mehr Zeit zur
Anpassung gegeben argumentiert die
Ampelkoalition den dringend benötigten
nachwuchsschrecken solche Maßnahmen ab
kritisiert Niedersachsens
bauernpräsident es finden fast keine
Investitionen mehr statt und das macht
uns die große Sorge dass die Betriebe un
der jetzigen politischen Lage wenig
Perspektive sehen ihren Betrieb
weiterzuentwickeln und das ist die
größte Gefahr für die Landwirtschaft in
Niedersachsen dass die jungen Leute
keinen Anreiz mehr haben in die Betriebe
einzusteigen und den dann auch nach
weiter zu weiterzentwickeln das
auslaufende
agrardieselsubvention zumutbar meinen
agrarökonomen
also die landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe
in Deutschland befinden sich derzeit in
ein finanziell sehr stabilen Situation
die Landwirtschaft in den letzten Jahren
enorm von den hohen Lebensmittelpreisen
profitiert höfeesterben ist da nicht zu
befürchten die Landwirte überzeugt das
Einlenken der Bundesregierung nicht die
angekündigten bundesweiten
Demonstrationen ab Montag sie werden
stattfinden ja die Regierung sagt also
wir haben noch mal intensiv gesprochen
weil wir die lastung für die Landwirte
sehen jetzt kann man sagen die hätte man
auch von Anfang an sehen können oder
eben entscheiden wir machen das
angesichts der Gesamtlage dennoch so
bringen wir Diana Zimmermann mit dazu in
Berlin
Diana da bist du guten Abend guten Abend
hat sich denn jetzt die Macht der Bauern
gezeigt oder die Schwäche einer
Regierung das eine schließt das andere
nicht aus die Bauern jedenfalls waren
sehr schnell sehr präsent mit ihren
Toren am Brandenburger Tor der
Landwirtschaftsminister war dabei und
Druck aus den Ländern gab es in den
vergangenen Wochen auch der Schluss
liegt glaube ich nah dass die ampe
tatsächlich auf die Macht der Bauern
reagiert hat auf ihre Proteste und
vielleicht noch mehr auf ihre
angekündigten Drohungen im
Bundeskanzleramt selbst sagt man
natürlich das sind rein inhaltliche
Beweggründe für diese kehtwende jetzt
der Landwirtschaftsminister habe ja von
Anfang an darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass
die Belastung bei den Landwirten zu groß
sei das wollle man jetzt korrigieren und
die Einführung der kfzsteuer für die
Land und Forst forstwirtschaftlichen
Fahrzeuge sei extrem bürokratisch das
ist ihn jetzt aufgefallen also wird die
fallen gelassen der Eindruck aber dass
eine kurze drohgebde der Bauern
ausreicht um die Ampel zu einer
kertwende zu bewegen ist natürlich ein
Signal das noch lange Folgen haben
könnte ein Signal das sagt wer
protestiert das hat Recht die den den
Bauernverband hat das in keinster Weise
beschwichtigt die wollen eben
weitermachen und ihnen schließ sich
jetzt auch noch das Speditionsgewerbe an
das protestiert gegen die Erhöhung der
LKW Maut mal gucken wer sich sonst noch
aufgerufen fühlt jetzt ist es ja Diana
nicht das erste Mal dass da etwas
vereinbart und angekündigt wird und dann
wird zurückgerudert Stichwort Vertrauen
in Regierungshandeln Stichwort Klarheit
von Regierungshandeln was sagt das alles
denn über die handwerklichen Fähigkeiten
dieser Bundesregierung
aus nichts Gutes zumil die Ampel selbst
immer davon spricht dass sie so klar ist
nach der Einigung im Dezember et war
hieß es der Haushalt steht jetzt posten
könnten überhaupt nur noch innerhalb von
Ministerien verschoben werden und jetzt
haben wir den Fall dass plötzlich doch
wieder Geld aufgetaucht ist und zwar aus
der Versteigerung von Lizenzen für
Offshore Windanlagen Geld das nicht zum
Agrarministerium gehört das nun aber den
die Subventionierung des agrardiesels
fördert und dieses Geld hätte eigentlich
in meeresprojekte fließen sollen die
ersten Klimaschützer beschweren sich
natürlich schon insgesamt hat man halt
den Eindruck dass die Ampel so viel KfT
in die Kommunikation untereinander
steckt dass die inhaltliche Arbeit
darunter leidet und erst recht die
Kommunikation nach außen Diana
Zimmermann herzlichen Dank für deine
Analyse Diana heute Abend live aus
Berlin und wir bleiben noch einen Moment
in der Politik gehen zu unserem nächsten
Thema Bundeskanzler im
Hochwasser spätestens seit Gerhard
Schröder in Gummistiefeln bei den
schlimmen Überschwemmungen in Sachsen
2002 ist das sowohl ein muss als auch
eine Chance diese Bilder so heißt es
später haben mit zu Schröders Wahlsieg
damals beigetragen Olaf Scholz wurde
kurz danach Generalsekretär der SPD er
dürfte damals genau hingeguckt haben und
er hat heute genau hingeguckt wollte
sich im Hochwassergebiet von
SachsenAnhalt selbst ein Bild der
angespannten Lage machen generell gilt
Entwarnung gibt es nach wie vor nicht
oder wie die Meteorologen sagen sind
immer noch von Tiefs regelrecht
umzingelt den Bundeskanzler verfolgt
derweil nicht nur im Hochwassergebiet
sondern auch in der Tagespolitik die
Diskussion ob die Schuldenbremse für
hochwasserhilfen eine Ausnahme machen
sollte Andreas Weise mit
mehr kurz vor Mittag der Hubschrauber
mit den politischen Spitzen aus Bund und
Land landet auf dem Sportplatz von
Oberröblingen begleitet von einigen
Unmutsäußerungen machen sich Kanzler
Scholz Umweltministerin Lemke und Sachen
als Ministerpräsident haselow ein Bild
von der Lage an der Helme eigentlich ein
Flüsschen jetzt gleicht sie eher einer
Seenlandschaft die Deiche müssen weiter
verstärkt werden damit sie nicht
aufweichen vor allem der große Einsatz
der Helfer imponiert den
Bundeskanzler keiner guckt auf die Uhr
alle geben das Beste was sie geben
können um zu gewährleisten dass das
Hochwasser nicht die Konsequenzen hat
die es haben könnte wenn es nicht
ständig teichverteidigung ständig
konrenschaen und alle sich einsetz das
machen viele Freiwillige wie Anna
Katharina kutzle sie hilft beim Befüllen
der Sandsäcke seit letzter Woche sind
mehr als eine Millionen davon im
Hochwassergebiet verbaut worden
eigentlich mussute arbeiten aber ich
habe mich ab um 12r abgemeldet damit ich
mit helfen kann die Feuerwehr ist
überlastet und wir gucken halt einfach
dass wir das alle irgendwie halbwegs gut
über die Büne kriegen die Einätze kosten
Geld die Beseitigung der Schäden
irgendwann auch stellt sich wieder die
Frage wer das alles bezahlen soll wir
werden dazu im Kontakt bleiben wenn es
darum geht auch im nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen und auch
im nächsten Vereinbarung entsprechend
die Regulierung der SCH der Schäden
gemeinsam vorzunehmen heißt dass auch
der Bund ins Portemonnaie greifen soll
woher das Geld dann kommt noch offen
einige auch aus Scholz SPD bringen eine
weitere Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse
ins Spiel der Kanzler ist da auf
Nachfrage
zurückhaltend hinterher werden wir
gucken wie groß die Schäden sind und was
das bedeutet und daraus dann unsere
Schlüsse ziehen aber klar ist das wird
nur gemeinsam gehen und das muss auch
solidarisch in Deutschland erfolgen und
die Entscheidung werden wir dann
zwischen Bund und Ländern intensiv
eraten und
treffen sprach und machte sich auf den
Weg zurück nach Berlin dass es heute
nicht viel regnet entspannt die Lage an
der Helme kaum denn es ist das nahe
randvolle Staubecken von Kelbra das
große Sorgen bereitet ist am Maximum
angekommen und muss deswegen größere
Wassermengen abgeben und das sorgt jetzt
für die Probleme vor Ort also nicht nur
das was von oben kommt sondern das was
aus der Talsperre abgelassen wird ist
das Problem hier für die Region wir sind
da aber im engen Austausch und jetzt
geht's darum die Deiche zu verteidigen
was wird mit dem Stausee halten die
Deiche Fragen die den Menschen hier im
südlichen Sachsen Anhalt noch einige
unruhige Tage bescheren
werden und jetzt eine neue Entwicklung
nach dem verheerenden Anschlag gestern
in Iran mit Nachrichten aus dem Ausland
beginnst du jetzt Hanna die
terrormilizislamischer Staat hat den
Anschlag in Iran mit mehr als 80 Toten
und über 280 verletzten für sich
reklamiert demnach sollen gestern in der
Stadt kerm zwei Attentäter
Sprengstoffgürtel gezündet haben die
Explosionen ereigneten sich während
einer Trauerveranstaltung zum Todestag
eines wichtigen iranischen Generals 2020
war dieser von den USA getötet worden
das Regime in teiran hatte für den
heutigen Tag Staatstrauer
angeordnet die israelische Armee hat
unterdessen ihre Angriffe im
Gazastreifen fortgesetzt vor allem im
Süden des Gebiets in der Stadt
hananjunis sein Kämpfer der Hamas in
Tunneln getötet worden erklärte das
israelische Militär auf telegram nach
Aussage der Hamas
Gesundheitsbehörde ist die Zahl der
getöteten Palästinenser mittlerweile auf
mehr als
22400 gestiegen die Angaben lassen sich
nicht unabhängig
überprüfen das Auswärtige Amt hat die
deutschen Staatsangehörigen im Libanon
erneut aufgefordert das Land so schnell
wie möglich zu verlassen grund sei die
angeswannte Lage an der Grenze zwischen
Israel und dem Libanon nachdem am
Dienstag in Beirut ein hamasanführer
getötet worden war eine Eskalation sei
nicht auszuschließen hieß es die
ausreiseaufforderung gilt seit dem 19
Oktober Rentnerinnen und Rentner die im
Osten Deutschlands leben können sich von
ihrem Geld mehr leisten als die die im
Westen wohnen zu diesem Schluss kommt
das Forschungsinstitut Prognos die
Kaufkraft der Renten variiere regional
um bis zu 70% in Gera lag 2021 die
monatliche Kaufkraft einer
Durchschnittsrente mit
1437 € am höchsten gefolgt von Kemnitz
und cotbus am niedrigsten lag sie im
Eifelkreis bittburg in Rheinlandpfalz
mit
€ der remzm Führer Thomas Drach ist
erneut verurteilt worden zu 15 Jahren
Haft und anschließender
Sicherungsverwahrung das Kölner
Landgericht sprach ihn wegen mehrerer
bewaffneter Raubüberfälle auf
Geldtransporter und versuchten Mordes in
den Jahren 2018 und 19 schuldig Drach
ist einer der wohl bekanntesten
Schwerverbrecher Deutschlands 1996
entführte er den Hamburger Millionär Jan
Philip remzmar und ließ ihn erst gegen
eine Lösegeldzahlung von 30 Millionen
DMark frei für die Tat war Drach zu 14
Jahren und 6 Monaten Haft verurteilt
worden
5,9% das ist die amtliche Zahl in der
Statistik für dieses unerfreuliche
Phänomen dass wir alle jeden Tag spüren
beim Blick auf Rechnungen im Restaurant
im Geldbeutel
5,9% das ist die Teuerungsrate in
Deutschland im Jahr
2023 damit zog die Inflation im
Vergleich zum Jahr davor weniger stark
an aber es ist immer noch der
zweithöchste Wert seit der
Wiedervereinigung woran das liegt und
vor allem wie es jetzt weitergeht zeigt
Andreas
linke dass die Dinge teurer geworden
sind merken sie auch im Supermarkt in
Stuttgart Obertürkheim auch wenn sie
sich ein bisschen daran gewöhnt haben
was man braucht muss man halt kaufen es
geht nicht anders gucken wo man
biligchen einkaufen K ja dann nehme ich
auch mal andere Marken nicht nur
die normalen was man kennt so natürlich
überlegt man sich habe ich aber vorher
auch schon überlegt ob man was man kauft
oder was nicht
aber ich beschränke mich da nicht ein
die Lebensmittelpreise haben in den
vergangenen beiden Jahren besonders
zugelegt 2023 um
14,5% ForscherInnen wie virena hüttelm
beobachten die Reaktionen die
Verbraucherin ihr Verhalten inoweit an
dass sie stärker auf Rabatte achten dass
sie eher zum Discounter gehen dass sie
so Zusatzleistungen die Produkte
beinhalten wie das ein Beitrag für die
Nachhaltigkeit geleistet wird oder auch
fair Handel Bio sowas wird
zurückgefahren und man beschränkt sich
stärker auf das Wesentliche in die
Berechnung der allgemeinen
Inflationsrate fließt eine große Zahl an
Gütern ein sowie auch die Kraftstoff und
Energiepreise
5,9% beträgt die so ermittelte allgem
meine teurungsrate in
2023 vor 3 Jahren begann die aktuelle
Steigerung der Verbraucherpreise nah mit
dem russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine
noch mehr Fahrt auf und der
Finanzexperte Hans-peter burkhof sieht
noch weiteres auf uns zukommen wir haben
viele Zweitrundeneffekte die Löhne gehen
hoch dadurch steigen die Preise viele
Unternehmen wollen die Preise erhöhen
der Staat fährt Unterstützungsmaßnahmen
zurück die den Preisanstieg abgedämmt
haben das heißt also wir können noch
einige böse Überraschung bei der
Inflation erleben die Europäische
Zentralbank habe inzwischen die
Inflation einigermaßen in den Griff
bekommen sagt bkof sie dürfe aber nicht
nachlassen das spricht dafür dass sie
jetzt vorsichtig sein muss dass sie
nicht einfach dem Ruf der Politik und
der Wirtschaft folgen und die Zinsen
senken darf sondern sie muss an der
Reputation arbeiten dass es wirklich er
zel ist den Geldwert zu verteidigen eine
gewisse Inflationsangst bleibt in den
Menschen auch wenn es ja
Ausgleichszahlungen von Staat und
Arbeitgebern gab die Menschen haben
Angst um ihre Grundausstattung also das
was sie gewohnt sind zu haben und
Inflation wird empfunden wie ein Verlust
und Verluste wiegen für die menschliche
Psyche stärker als Gewinne in der
gleichen Höhe und die Aussichten auf ein
Ende der Krisen die die Inflation
auslösten sind gering was auch für das
beginnende Jahr bedeutet nur die
Unsicherheit ist
sicher und noch eine wichtige Zahl heute
der Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen in
Deutsch Land ist auf dem tiefsten Stand
seit 70 Jahren eine Studie der
Denkfabrik agora Energiewende sieht ihn
2023 GEG über dem Vorjahr umfast 10%
niedriger Grund sei weniger Kohlestrom
und etwas was man sicher eher nicht
wünscht die Wirtschaftsflaute nämlich
Deutschland kommt beim Umbau der
Energieversorgung also schneller voran
als zuletzt aber der Weg zu den
selbstgesetzten Zielen ist noch weit
auch deshalb bringen manche immer wieder
die die Atomkraft in die Diskussion aus
der Deutschland ja vergangenes Jahr
komplett ausgestiegen ist ganz im
Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern die die
Nutzung der Kernenergie massiv
verstärken wollen wie steht Deutschland
also da eine Bilanz von jotta
sonnewald für die Atomkraftgegner ist
der 15 April 2023 ein guter Tag nach 61
Jahren 9 Monaten und 29 Tagen gehen in
Deutschland die letzten drei Atommeiler
darunter auch das bayerische Kraftwerk
is V Netz ausgerechnet Markus Söder
dessen CSU es einst nicht schnell genug
gehen konnte mit dem Atomausstieg
fordert jetzt zum Wohle des Klimas eine
kehtwende das Ausstiegszenario war zum
falschen Zeitpunkt in der falschen
Dimension es war rein ideologisch
geprägt ausbauneuerbarer jah aber für
die grundlastfähigkeit und für den
tatsächlichen Reduktion von CO2 brauchen
wir wie alle anderen Industrieländer die
Kernenergie eine Rückkehr zur Atomkraft
dafür plediert der Verband der
bayerischen Energiewirtschaft zwar nicht
mnt aber dass im Freistaat im Dunkeln
und bei Windstille rasch eine
Versorgungslücke entstehen könne denn in
Bayern gebe es weder genügend
alternative Kraftwerke noch ausreichend
langfristige Stromspeicher wir sehen ja
schon seit mehreren Jahren dass die
Unternehmen die viel Strom verbrauchen
sich nicht mehr in Bayern ansiedeln die
gehen eher in den Norden wo es dann auch
die Windkraft gibt die bei uns nicht
oder kaum zur Verfügung steht das ist
für uns momentan ein
Standortnachteil in der Tat gibt es
regionale Unterschiede so kommt in
Süddeutschland der Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien schleppender voran und es
fehlen Stromtrassen von Nord nach Süd
doch bundesweit habe der Atomausstieg
weder die Versorgungssicherheit im Land
beeinträchtigt noch die Strompreise nach
oben getrieben so die
Bundesnetzagentur aufgrund des
Atomausstieges können wir
Preissteigerung nicht sehen ganz im
Gegenteil im Jahr 23 wo ja jetzt die
letzten drei Atomkraftwerke vom Netz
gegangen sind haben wir sinkende
Strompreise gesehen weil es im Ausland
günstige Alternativen gibt weil die
Erneuerbaren in Deutschland ausgebaut
werden all das drückt die Preise das ist
gut und wir sehen dass der europäische
Stromhandel funktioniert hat gerade weil
es im Ausland preisgünstiger war haben
wir regenerativen Strom aus Skandinavien
aber auch teilweise Atomstrom aus
Frankreich bezogen laut dem Frauenhofer
Institut für solare Energiesysteme hatte
die Kernenergie 2023 nur noch einen
Anteil von 1,5% an der öffentlichen net
Stromerzeugung erneuerbare Energien
deckten mit einem rekordanteil von
59,7% erstmals über die Hälfte des
Stromverbrauchs in Deutschland ab auf
der Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai die vor
wenigen Wochen zu Ende ging empfahl die
weltwetterorganisation Deutschland
seinen Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft zu
überdenken für die Grünen undenkbar wir
sehen beispielsweise an den
Atomkraftwerken in Frankreich dass diese
oft stillstehen weil sie entweder
repariert werden müssen ähm die
Temperaturen in den Flüssen zu hoch sind
etc pp und deswegen ist es keine
verlässliche Energieform in der Nähe des
abgeschalteten bayerischen Atommeilers
Isa 2 hat Anfang Dezember der Bau des
südostlinks begonnen über diese
stromautobahn soll in drei Jahren jede
Menge Windstrom aus Norddeutschland nach
Bayern fließen spätestens dann soll auch
im Freistaat die Stromlücke geschlossen
sein so das Thema führen wir jetzt noch
für ein Moment weiter und zwar mit di
Hann du hast es gerade schon
angesprochen der CO2 Ausstoß in
Deutschland ist überraschend stark
zurückgegangen auf den tiefsten Stand
seit den 50er Jahren doch das könnte
sich schon bald wieder ändern Frank
betmann ein Hauptgrund ist die lahende
Wirtschaft und da hoffen wir ja
eigentlich auf neuen Schwung ja und
damit sind wir beim Dilemma wenn nämlich
die besonders energieintensive Industrie
wieder loslegt weil die Konjunktur
wieder in Schwung kommt dann dürften
eben die Treibhausemissionen auch wieder
steigen aber vielleicht nicht mehr ganz
so stark wie in der Vergangenheit denn
im vergangenen Jahr konnte ja bereits
mehr Strom aus erneuerbaren Quellen
gewonnen werden gleichzeitig importierte
Deutschland mehr Strom aus dem Ausland
weswegen eben auch hier zulande weniger
Strom durch Kohle erzeugt wurde so in
etwa müsste es also weitergehen
allerdings ist der bislang
eingeschlagene Weg noch nicht besonders
nachhaltig nur 15% der bislang
erreichten Minderung seinen langfristig
gesichert heißt es dazu in der
entsprechenden Studie
wie stark sind die Emissionen denn in
anderen Bereichen gesunken jetzt mal
abseits von Industrie und Energie ja da
ist bildlich gesprochen noch viel
saubere Luft nach oben in der
Landwirtschaft sind die Emissionen nur
leicht gesunken und im Verkehr und bei
den Gebäuden den beiden großen
Sorgenkindern gingen die ausstoßwerte
ebenfalls nur geringfügig zurück Bau und
Verkehrssektor verfehlten dabei zum
wiederholten Mal die selbstgesteckten
Klimaziele vielen Dank Frank für deine
Einschätzung und es gibt weiterhin eine
aktuelle Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes und zwar vor ergiebigem
Dauerregen in Teilen von
nordrinwestfalen Rheinlandpfalz und
Hessen der erste fC Köln hat einen neuen
Trainer Timo Schulz wird Nachfolger von
Steffen Baumgard und soll den
Bundesligisten vor dem Abstieg bewahren
der 46-Jährige war zuletzt Cheftrainer
beim Schweizer Erstligisten FC Basel
davor trainierte er den FC sank pauli wo
er in der vergangen auch als Spieler
aktiv
war se Tage vor der Heim em sind die
deutschen Handballer heute im Testspiel
auf Portugal getroffen und durften sich
über einen Sieg freuen auch wenn der
alles andere als mühelos gelang Portugal
zeigte sich als starker Gegner am Ende
stand es 34 z33 für das deutsche Team
auch wegen Andy Wolf im Tor und Juri
Knorr der als bester deutscher Werfer
sechs Treffer landet
und zum Schluss eine Geschichte aus dem
Kosovo die im weitesten Sinn mit Musik
zu tun hat jedenfalls nicht wie so
häufig wenn wir aus der Region berichten
mit Konflikt und Krise und dennoch ist
auch sie politisch wie eigentlich jedes
Thema in der balkanrepublik die eine der
jüngsten Nationen Europas ist mehr als
die Hälfte der 1,8 Millionen Kosovaren
sind unter 30 ein Drittel jünger als 18
wir wissen nicht wie alt die Stars des
Beitrages jetzt sind von unserer
Korrespondentin Britta Hilpert aber sie
werden Ihnen so schnell nicht mehr aus
dem Kopf gehen bzw aus den
Ohren ja er krät und krät immer noch
denn das ist Sinn und Zweck seines
Daseins kein Hahn krät länger als der
Kosovo
langkrer die schönhit des Gesangs ist
kein Kriterium erzählt der Züchter bayam
ilasi auch die Mütter werden nur danach
bewertet wie lange die Söhne kräen von
ihr kommen h die mehr als 70 Sekunden
krä auf der geflügelmesse in Pristina
ist der langkrer einer der Stars der
Hahn in den albanischen Nationalfarben
soll nun als eigene Rasse anerkannt
werden eine Frage des Nationalstolzes
für den jungen Staat Kosovo für
albanischstämmige Züchter wie bayam
ilasi
das stärkste Charakteristikum dieser
Rasse ist dass die Hähne wie die Albaner
sind hartnäckig und
dicköpfig das stpotenzial des landrers
hat sich bis Deutschland herum
gesprochen bei Wetten das macht er
F es ging darum die Rasse zu erraten das
war ziemlich
leicht Kosovo msste das und die Wette
damit
gewonnen es macht uns stolz dass unser
Hahn in einer deutschen Sendung war und
es motiviert uns diese Rasse weiter zu
verbess seit seinem Sieb lebensjahr
züchtet BAM ilasi Hühner verschiedener
Rassen aber der langkrer liegt ihm
besonders am Herzen denn wie so vieles
im Kosovo geht es dabei auch um
Abgrenzung zur serbischen Konkurrenz ein
Hahn in rotschwarz mit eindrucksvollem
imponiergabe der kann doch nur aus dem
Kosovo
sein die Serben haben immer versucht
sich unsere Rassen anzueignen und ihn zu
ihrer eigenen Rasse zu machen aber es
gibt Beweise dafür dass der Hahn seinen
Ursprung im Kosovo
hat der langkreer ist eigenwillig das
ist sicher zum Abschied wollte er sogar
nicht Krähen weder lang noch kurz
was da hätte ich ihn so gerne noch mal
gehört und denkt er erstickt es gibt
eine ganze Reihe von ihnen ihnen
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern die gerade
zu süchtig sind nachdem was gerade nach
uns läuft im ZDF großes journalistisches
Kino nächtliche Streifzüge durch die
absoluten mega cities dieser Welt heute
eine Stadt in die die allermeisten wohl
eher selten selbst Reisen werden eine
Mega City der extreme im Club wird so
viel Champagner getrunken wie sonst nur
in Paris und gleichzeitig kämpfen
Millionen ums Überleben und die Stadt
wächst bis Ende des Jahrhunderts könnte
sie so viele Einwohner haben wie
Deutschland wie ganz Deutschland kommen
sie mit nach Lagos jetzt gleich nach uns
und die nächsten Nachrichten gibt's dann
hier gegen 025 Uhr dann begrüßt Sie
Laura B mit unserem heute journal Update
ein angenehmen Abend tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend sehen Sie hier das neue
Tiefdruck ABC des noch jungen Jahres das
Tief Annelie das Tief Brigitta und das
Tief Charlotte die Kaltfront von tief
Annelie zieht jetzt ostwärts ab dann
kommt die warmfon von tief Brigitta und
es entwickelt sich eine wettergrenze
hier im Nordosten Deutschlands und das
Italien tief Charlotte bringt Regen und
Schnee in die Alpen und etwas auch auf
die Alpen Nordseite heute Nacht sollten
Sie sich auf gefährlich glatte Straßen
gefasst machen hier so zwischen der
Lausitz und dem Emsland durch
Schneeregen zum frühen Morgen auch durch
Glatteisregen im Süden bleibt es dagegen
trocken und vor allen Dingen rund um das
Sauerland regnet es noch kräftig weiter
die Temperaturen sinken im Nordosten bis
-4° deutlich milder bleibt die Nacht am
niederrein mit 7° und morgen verschärfen
sich die Gegensätze noch es bleibt beim
Dauerfrost hier im Nordosten bei -1 bis
0° am oberrein werden 11° erreicht und
so sollten Sie sich auch morgen hier im
Nordosten auf gefährliche straßenglätter
einstellen durch Schnee und Schneeregen
es gibt einen freundlichen Streifen
ungefähr zwischen dem Main und der Donau
und das italientief bringt dann im Süden
badenwürttembergs und Bayerns Regen und
in den höheren Lagen auch Schnee mit und
apropos Schnee das wird eine ganze Menge
werden bis Montag können am Alpenrand
durchaus 50 cm Neuschnee fallen und hier
in norddeutch stand 5 bis 20 cm
Neuschnee die gute Nachricht für die
Hochwassergebiete ist der Dauerregen
wird jetzt abgelöst durch Kälte und
Sonnenschein von Norden guten Abend